so we return now to offer some light and
hope and guidance to the poor souls on
reddit over at the mi the [ __ ] forum
um these are people who suspect
you know that that they might be animals
but the world needs adults they're
curious if they're [ __ ] uh but
they're not sure so they go to write it
and they and they ask these questions
they pose these quandaries and i will
read some of them and we'll try to try
to lend a little bit of clarity so we'll
start here am i the outsole for venmo
requesting money from a tinder date
after he crapped in my car all right now
we're getting into the nitty-gritty here
a couple weeks ago i 19 year old female
went on a tinder date with a guy who i
knew from high school
we were mutual acquaintances before this
and when we matched on tinder we agreed
to meet up
pick him up at seven and we went and got
some food
after that we drove to some secluded
place so we could talk with extra
privacy leave it up to the imagination
anyway around 10 30 he starts to
complain about his stomach hurting i
asked him if he wants to leave and he
says no and kind of blows it off for a
little bit around 11 he says he really
needs to use the bathroom i wasn't sure
what to do because we were in a very
secluded area and i wasn't familiar with
uh he tells me that there's a gas
station about 15 minutes away from us
and asks me to step on it i leave and
drive as fast as i can but it's very
dark
i don't know my way around he's becoming
more more frantic visibly sweating
breathing heavy at one point i asked if
i should pull over because going in the
woods is better than nothing but he
swears he could make it unfortunately he
misses telling me to take a turn
somewhere and we get lost i have to turn
around and it's probably like 10 more
minutes according to him then he gets
very pale and yells at me to pull over
and i stop as fast as i can but what i
do he doesn't get out of the car he just
sits very resigned
at that point i understood it was too
late i came to understand it was too
late i wonder how you understood that we
both sat there in silence for a little
bit i really wasn't sure what to say to
make him feel better oh man this is a
nightmare and i was also feeling a
little sick from the whole thing
parentheses the smell
thank you for clarifying that because i
wouldn't have known eventually i just
offered to take him home and try to act
nonchalant
try to act nonchalant while this guy's
sitting in his own you know just be on
just be cool about it he agreed so i
drove us home he also tells me that he
will reimburse me for getting my car
cleaned i felt bad because of course it
wasn't his fault accidents happened so i
offered to split the cost 50 50 and we
never talk about it again
i also told him if he if he wants i'd
like to try a second date
wow
you
are either very forgiving or have very
low standards or both since this one
turned out not so well he thanked me and
we parted ways i got my car detailed and
sent him a text letting him know
everything went well but i didn't get a
response i waited for another week and
tried texting him again like hey did you
see my text and again he didn't respond
i went on tinder to try and message him
there but i saw he had unmatched me it
was pretty clear that he had ghosted me
i was pretty pissed not gonna lie
because i thought i was chill about the
whole situation it's cool if he didn't
want to see me again but he could have
still kept up his end of the deal i went
looking for his instagram to try and
message him there and when i find i see
he had his venmo in his bio i decided to
venmo request in the description i put
the poop emoji
the pointed finger and my card
communicating now at hieroglyphics you
know because regular communication
hasn't worked surprisingly i get a quick
response he sends the money but he also
texts me pissed because he said his
friends would be able to see what i put
and would probably put two and two
together
um i told him i wouldn't have done that
if he hadn't ghosted me am i the answer
okay well
that was uh
that was a story you know
first of all
this is what you get
for having the girl drive thanks
it's one of the many reasons why you as
the man should be taking control of the
situation if you are the one who's
driving then you would have more control
of the situation this probably wouldn't
happen
but beyond that you know i'm not really
sure i'm kind of torn on this
who's the [ __ ] in the store i mean
there's there's definitely one [ __ ]
in the story a very a very active one
you're a sick [ __ ] but um beyond that
particular i mean
i can't blame you for for not wanting to
have to foot the bill to clean the
stains in your car
but at the same time i can't really
blame the other guy for for hiding away
in shame
it's hard for me to blame him for that
part of it
what else are you gonna do
i mean you texted him and said
everything you text him and said after
you got the car cleaned you texted him
and said everything went well
went well with cleaning
from your upholstery
how do you even respond to that as the
guy you insensitive [ __ ] what's he
supposed to say
thumbs up emoji smiley face cool
congrats on cleaning up my
so there's no good answer here and this
is but this is also here's another thing
this is why
you know i'm so glad that i'm married
so that i can in my car without judgment
also because if you're married and
you're in that situation and we've all
been in situations
like that when you're in the car there's
a little bit of a bathroom emergency but
if you're married now you can have an
honest conversation in a situation like
that you could just say
when you're dating right and you just
met this person or you're going your
first date you don't want to be honest
about it and so that's when the crisis
starts but when you're married you'll
just say listen i'm gonna shut my pants
if you don't find me a bathroom within
five minutes
all right um so who's the soul i you
know i i i guess it's got to be him he
is the guy who showed your car after all
if you feel like you are getting the
respect you deserve in life well i've
got a solution for you establish titles
is your opportunity to earn the title of
lord or lady and gain the respect you
deserve all you need is a one square
foot plot of land in scotland and your
title pack you'll receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land these title packs
are a fantastic gift and the best way to
surprise your loved ones from
girlfriends or boyfriends or even family
you could even get a couple pack for you
and your partner where you can get
adjoining plots of land
well with this certificate you could
officially change your name to lord or
lady and get it on your credit card your
plane ticket etc established titles is
having a great extended new year's sale
so go to establishtitles.com matt walsh
to save 10 off today and remember to use
the discount code matt walsh or just
click the link below that's established
titles dot com slash matt walsh or just
click the link below all right finally
well two more here i think let's see my
daughter came out as transgender a few
years ago and for her birthday this year
we legally changed her first name to a
feminine name of her choosing my wife
and i have always supported her and her
transition but my daughter seemed
disappointed that her surname wasn't
also changed
i am icelandic american um if you don't
know surnames are quite different than
in other countries one surname is their
father's first name and a suffix related
to their gender
the son of joe cool would be jokalson
and the daughter of jokul would be jokal
doter
when my american wife and i married she
took my last name per american custom
and gave that same masculine surname to
our daughter which she was born all of
us have the same masculine last name my
daughter wishes to change her surname to
jokal doter in order to align with her
gender expression as well as icelandic
naming customs i hadn't considered this
for her as we live in the united states
and use the local customs my wife and i
are on the fence about changing her
legal name again as processes like this
are very expensive and time consuming i
told her that her mother and i would be
more than happy to help with the
paperwork if she paid for the processing
our daughter doesn't accept our
reasoning and claims that we're only
contributing to our existing dysphoria
by not going through the process again
so our am ideal for making my
transgender daughter pay for her own
surname change
but no absolutely not you are not the
soul for that
you are the soul for everything else in
this story
starting with the fact that you were
supportive
of your son pretending to be a girl
so your son and did you say how old your
son is oh 17 okay
uh your son has
two problems here and this is your son
we're dealing with
your son is um a self-entitled
narcissist
demanding you have to pay for everything
or my dysphoria is gonna be worse this
is emotional blackmail
um and this is in in gender ideology
it's very common this is one of
you know the the propagandists that that
that voice this stuff on kids they
encourage this kind of emotional
blackmail oh to get everything you want
just tell your loved ones that you know
you're gonna that uh you're gonna have
just dysphoria and you'll be in
emotional pain if they don't do
literally everything you want
so this is self-entitled narcissism and
it's also you know a certain element of
you know just
sincere confusion as well
and you as the the parent as the adult
you're supposed to be a voice of reason
you're supposed to be a clarifying
presence
and by supporting your son in his
delusions his narcissism his confusion
uh you are dooming him to a life of
despair and that's what makes you
awesome all right finally am i the
answer for calling the police on my
fiance
my fiancee 28 male and i 30 female have
been together for three years i used to
live close to work and use public
transportation but after i moved in to
his house which is hours away from work
i bought myself a car since i'm a nurse
and also since there isn't any hospitals
close to where we live that i could
transfer to you know one thing about
about these things is that um
all of these people are [ __ ] for
giving way too much information we don't
need any of this background still go in
this [ __ ] let's just get to the story
please
my fiance's car hasn't been able to work
for close to two months now it requires
so much money to get it fixed and he
refused my financial help when i offered
it instead he would ask to use my car
every now and then and i agreed as long
as it's when i'm not working and also
since he only uses it for trips to the
supermarket etc
on new year's eve he told me he wanted
to use my car to go hang out with his
friends and celebrate but i declined
because i had to cover a night shift and
needed my car to travel to work he
insisted and even suggested that i take
the night off or swap shifts with
another nurse but i couldn't do that at
the last minute oh my gosh okay blah
blah blah
fast forwarding she doesn't want to give
the car up and he decides to take it
anyway without asking her and he drives
off to go to his new year's party she
tries to call him and uh and can't get a
hold of him and then finally does talk
to him 30 minutes later and she's pissed
so she calls the cops to report him from
stealing the car okay and now she's he's
mad
are you the [ __ ] for that uh and he
also says that he can take the car
and she shouldn't have called the police
because they're engaged and so he says
what's what's yours is mine what's mine
is yours
who's this well he's obviously [ __ ]
you [ __ ] he he did steal a car you
told him not to you asked him to bring
it back he didn't bring it back you
called the police
that's probably farther than i would
have taken it but i think it's justified
but here's the main point
uh
no it's not true that as an engaged
couple
what's yours is mine what's mine is
yours that's not true
that's marriage
so you don't get to take advantage of
that before the marriage even happens
that there isn't like this grace period
ahead of time
that's in marriage once you beca that's
again the point of marriage now you
share everything
and then if you take now it's the family
car
and if your spouse calls the police on
you for taking the family car even if
they don't agree with what you're doing
with it um then that's a different story
so get married is the uh
is the moral of the story
and then you can steal your spouse's car
all you want
and even
in it if you want